- [Voiceover] Hey grammarians,
today we're talking about
compound prepositions
which are prepositions
that have more than one syllable.
And a syllable is like a unit
of rhythmic measurement in language.
So for example you could say,
com-pound prep-o-si-tions.
Right so,
the word compound has two syllables here
and the word prep-o-si-tions
has four.
And it's how many rhythmic
word sounds there are.
That's all it means.
And it generally tends to mean that
a word is more complicated.
Adding to the complication is
that a lot of these words
have multiple meanings.
Beginning with between.
So between can have a literal meaning,
but it can also have a
metaphorical meaning.
And what it means is that when
you use between in a sentence,
you're considering multiple
objects as individuals.
So, between considers individuals.
I'll explain.
So you could say something literal.
Like, "The firefly zipped
between the raindrops."
Literally going in between each one.
But you could also use it
in an abstract, metaphorical way.
"What do you want to watch?
"I can't decide between
Humdinger! and Police-Cat."
Right, which are made up TV shows.
This describes not a
physical relationship,
but the relationship of ideas.
You're choosing between two ideas.
Or making a decision between two concepts.
Now, between often gets
confused with the word among.
And they do have distinct meanings.
Because where between
considers individuals,
among is a preposition
that considers collections.
So among considers collectively.
Among can also have a
literal, physical meaning.
Or a metaphorical meaning.
We could say something like,
"Ashley and Cyrus frolicked
among the daisies."
And we could say this
because we're not really
distinguishing between
each individual daisy,
the way that the firefly up here
in this sentence is distinguishing between
each individual raindrop
that it flies between.
I imagine Ashley and
Cyrus as dancing through
or frolicking through a field of daisies,
and they are not distinguishing
between each one.
You can also use among metaphorically.
And say, "Among the ideas you've had,
"I like this one best."
So considering the entire collection of
ideas that you might've had,
like say for a television show like
something called Humdinger! and
something called Police-Cat.
Among those ideas, among
like a multitude of ideas I like this one.
But the difference is, in
this in this prepositional
phrase, that we're just
sort of considering
all of those ideas as a collective group.
Let's look at some more prepositions.
Around is a word that has both
a literal and a metaphorical connotation.
And around is in the literal sense,
is pretty, pretty explanatory.
Pretty self-explanatory.
"The fox ran around the tree."
Right, so we got this tree,
then we got a little fox going around it.
There goes the weird lookin' little foxy.
But in the metaphorical sense,
we can also use this connotation of
going around something in a circle,
you know, "The mayor
talked around the issue."
You can use the word around as a metaphor
to say that someone is avoiding something.
By instead of addressing it head-on,
just going what, what's that?
Nope.
And here's your little trouble box, here.
So you can take this physical idea and
extend it into the realm of
the figurative in language.
Against, right, has this connotation
of opposing or opposition.
And literally you can say something like,
"Rudyard leaned heavily against a tree."
Or you can use it metaphorically,
by saying you're opposed to something,
you're opposed to an idea, right?
"Georgie campaigned against clog dancing."
Which for the record, is
a beautiful tradition.
Within is a word that basically
just means in or inside.
And you can use it literally,
you know, to say, "There's
a frog within the pond."
Which is maybe a little
ponderous but you get the idea.
But if you wanted to get metaphorical,
you could say non-literally,
"Who can say what is
within Ralph's heart?"
Right, and we're not
asking, you know, what's
the condition of his cardiac muscles,
we're not talking about the blood,
we're talking about what spiritually
or what emotionally is
going on inside Ralph.
Without is an interesting one because
it kinda has, it used to
mean something different.
It used to mean something
more akin to outside,
but now it has this
connotation of just not with.
It's the opposite of with.
"I guess we're going to the
Candy Planet without Stu, then."
All right, let's look
at two more examples.
So inside basically means the
same thing as in, or within.
You can use it much the same way
as you would use any of
those other two words.
So you could use it literally.
And ask, "What's inside the box?"
But we can also use
this kind of interiority
as a metaphor and say,
"What's inside her mind right now?"
Because the difference between that
and the literal sentence
is you can open the box,
you can't really open someone's mind.
Not physically, anyway.
You could open someone's mind by
showing them new foods and movies
and books and music and stuff.
But you can't really get inside
someone's head unless you're
a psychic mind wizard.
Finally, beyond.
And beyond is a preposition that
has this connotation of being
far away.
Like far away and past some point.
It also has a literal meaning
and it has a metaphorical meaning.
So for example, you could say literally,
"Beyond those mountains
is Terrell's kingdom."
Right, we're using these mountains
as like a literal, literal boundary.
Little snow-cap peaks.
And past them
is
Terrellia.
But you can also use it as a metaphor,
we can use this physical
relationship as a metaphor.
You can say something like,
"This strawberry's flavor is
"beyond anything I've ever had before."
Right, this is like the world's
most delicious strawberry and
its taste, its flavor,
surpasses, it goes past you know,
over the mountains and into Terrellia,
that's how delicious it is.
Oh my goodness, what a
strawberry, you know?
We're using this physical relationship
as a figurative metaphor.
We're using that to say
that this strawberry
over here is way better than
anything else that we've had previously.
Like this
square
rock.
This is, you used to eat rocks before.
Now you've had a strawberry
for the first time
and oh my goodness it's
just blowing you away.
Although we do eat rocks all the time,
if you think about what
salt is, technically.
Anyway, these are eight of the most
common compound prepositions.
There are more listed in the exercises.
You can learn anything.
David out.